le sport à présent il faut du souffle
dominique champeau l'événement de ce
samedi c'est bien sûr la finale de la
coupe de france de football entre le
paris saint-germain et auxerre ce soir
au stade de france
et c'est une affiche qui a priori
garantit le spectacle d'un côté
ronaldinho de l'autre cissé et entre les
deux la même motivation sauver une
saison un petit peu raté et puis la
possibilité également de se retrouver
européen la saison prochaine avec en
plus pour les parisiens l'occasion de
pouvoir tourner la page fernandez dans
de bonnes conditions à la dormance
c'est la dernière séance pour le tandem
laurent perpère et luis fernandez qui
ont écrit un bien mauvais scénario en
championnat la coupe de france est le
dernier salut pour sauver un film
parisien de la saison très décevant bien
sûr après après sept saisons que
malheureusement pas extraordinaire on a
besoin de gagner
c'était vraiment une catastrophe et
chaque année un type pour laurent
perpère est luis fernandez prendre quand
même l'amour du club malgré ce qu'on dit
l'armé fatale pour le paris saint
germain qui veut effacer sa piètre 11e
place au championnat
c'est le génial ronaldinho qui par son
talent individuel peut à lui seul gagner
cette coupe de france et offrir ainsi un
dernier cadeau à luis fernandez final on
va la jouer
88 personnes c'est notre dernier match
notre dernier bal à nous de le gagner à
nous de bien danser auxerre 6e en
championnat ne peut se qualifier
directement une coupe européenne les
bourguignons fort le cetia leurs
priorités
eux qui n'ont pas remporté le moindre
trophée depuis septembre avantage
psychologique pour djibril cissé sa
bande de copains qui s'était déjà imposé
au stade de france en finale de la coupe
gambardella
nous avons une équipe talentueuse mais
jeunes paris saint germain est également
très talenteux juskila la la défense
centrale de l'équipe d'argentine et
ronaldinho qui joue dans l'équipe du
brésil
ils ont un peu plus de maturité que nous
donc je ne nous donnerait entre 30 et
40% de chances de gagner mais en face et
déjà permettre beaucoup d'espoir pour le
paris saint germain qui vise un sixième
succès et l' aj auxerre
cette 85e édition de la coupe de france
sera l'occasion rêvée de s'assurer un
avenir européen